he is my colleague at the nfl media
group we will be hanging in the state of
ohio i am
assuming and uh he will have all the
answers three weeks from today of all
the questions to the
uh that i'm about to ask him and i'm
hoping he already knows the answers to
and i do believe if i'm not mistaken he
roots for the same team as somebody who
stuck his elbow
in the uh strike zone and got a win for
the new york mets yesterday just like
you tj jefferson
oh we'll be talking about that later on
i i saw it hit by a pitch that's all i
saw ian rappaport here on the rich
island
it's good to be on here good good to
talk to you yes um i look forward to
hanging out
in ohio as well standing six feet apart
um
and making sure that we can yell to each
other um which would be great
okay and um and i am accurate right that
uh
michael uh conforto not being socially
distant to a strike yesterday is
something that you
along with tj jefferson also rejoiced is
that correct
yeah i i honestly like i thought nothing
wrong with the win in my book
i would describe it as a win and i say
that
because i've been through a lot of the
mets fans so like
you can talk about how it was unfair or
he did something he shouldn't have and
then
you know ron culpa comes out and says he
made a mistake
and i'm like cool the universe still
owes me about a
thousand of these games that we lost we
should have won so like i'm not giving
this back
at all i am taking it and i am very
happy with it let's go back t.j
jefferson with an lgm as well correct i
couldn't agree more with what he just
said how are you
and everything else good i saw that you
went traveling with your beautiful
family as well so you got a little bit
of downtime
correct did i see that uh we did we went
to mississippi to go
uh hang out with my wife's family went
to a mississippi state football practice
went to mississippi baseball games at
the base
college baseball stadium in america um
and my boys loved it and they were we
had seats behind on plate
and espnu had a great shot of them just
wrestling each other
so great very refreshed you're ready for
the draft fantastic ian rap report here
on the rich eisen show
what are the 49ers going to do third
overall
best you can tell ian rappaport so
obviously the matt jones buzz is real i
know
he is someone that they are considering
i know that they really like him i know
he's someone that
kyle is very interested in when i asked
kyle shanahan about this i said you know
is this
basically like is this real is he
someone you're considering at three he
was like yeah
he is like we're definitely considering
him
um and a lot of the people who know kyle
shanahan well
will speak of his and mike shanahan's
you know love for mac jones so i think
a lot of the buzz is legit what i
don't 100 percent know is are they
actually doing it because if you
talk to other teams in the top 10 and
really just other teams in general
everyone agrees mac jones is a first
round pick not everyone
agrees that he should be picked there
so you know is he kirk cousins plus
for kyle maybe um
but i'm not 100 ready to say this is
definitely the guy let's move on to the
fourth pick
see but you know how this works though
um ian and in
the remarkable press conference that
shanahan and lynch held a couple of
weeks ago
for it it was so refreshing in its
in it's honesty to be honest with you
from kyle shanahan and
lynch even told you know a story uh
about going to jed york saying you know
we we like what we've got here uh all
that said we think that this is the
maneuver we should make you know
for long-term success so on and so forth
and jed york signed off on it do you
really think they went in
and that uh lynch made these deals and
they went back and forth to make sure
that the eagles were involved and nobody
found out about
any of this without really knowing for
sure
which of the three quarterbacks not
named lawrence
or wilson that they were going to make
all of these maneuvers
to go take really i mean i would
you're right in what you're thinking i
mean first of all it was amazing how
they engineered was essentially a
three-team trade
without anybody finding out about uh
until right when it happened
you know i mean i think there was about
20 minutes before the trade broke there
was some buzz that something major was
going on
but otherwise than that you know they
really kept a pretty good lit on it
um i would say they definitely know that
they are very happy with the third
quarterback whoever it is so like
they obviously know who they're not
getting i think everyone knows who
they're not getting right i mean that
would be trevor lawrence and zach wilson
i believe they are more than happy with
number three
um and i have a pretty good i mean it
seems like they know who they're taking
like i don't think right now they're
going all right let's
you know put the finishing touches on
our evaluation which
what i also know is that kyle shanahan
and john lynch have not told people in
their organization
so there's only a couple people who
actually
really know and they are not saying so
like we can talk about the mac jones
buzz and we have and
you know i think a lot of people
originally thought was for trail and
because he would probably sit here
i could make arguments on all sides but
i believe that
very few people actually know the answer
to this
did they ever reach out to the jets and
have a conversation i'm hearing yes i'm
hearing no
never did never even knocked on the door
for two number two overall
um and i'm wondering why because they
already gleaned from
from their former defensive coordinator
what the deal was
or they just assumed or like
i mean they they did talk to the jets uh
about darnold
and you know they i know that they were
very serious about darnold at the time
the jets weren't willing to deal him
really weren't really willing to
consider offers till they did the full
evaluation so they saw everyone throw in
person the jets really wanted to go
through the process
so they just weren't ready to deal and
then it sounds to me like
at that point probably around mid-march
the 49ers said all right we're just
moving on then like we're just figuring
out our next
quarterback situation we can't wait for
you know a month for darnold
so are you saying it's it's entirely
possible ian rappaport
that joe douglas could be could have
been sitting somewhere a couple fridays
ago saying
you know we talked about darnold why
don't we one and they asked me for the
second overall pick if that's what
they're giving up for number three
and that i mean and that and that lynch
and that
i'm sure that's exactly what happened
okay and so and that somewhere
lynch and shanahan might be sitting
there last week
saying we would have given up a a six
this year and a two and a four next year
for darnold
why why weren't they willing to do that
then
as opposed for us to have moved all the
way up to three is that possible
right now that could be happening i mean
i think the 49ers are going to be happy
with
sure what they have in the move they
made yeah the jets will be happy with
zach wilson too
you know but i mean oh 100 or whoever
goes to it could be anyone
what do you mean what does that mean ian
the jets are going to take zach wilson
aren't i i mean
right that's going to that's not in
question right yeah i mean
i would be it would be the shock of the
century if it's not zach wilson
but to go back to your point yes i do
actually think that's what happened they
talked about donald
they were getting ready to be done and
then at some point it was like wait why
haven't they asked about number two
everybody knew the jets didn't want to
trade number two i was i've been
surprised that
they haven't gotten any offers and
almost no calls or conversations for
number two
just like i'm sure nobody's called the
jaguars for one because
i have a pretty good sense they're not
trading that thing
so we move on to ian rappaport to
the falcons what's their evaluation
right now
best you can tell uh so i think a lot of
people believe the falcons are taking a
quarterback
i don't know that for sure but that is
what people believe one that they didn't
end up doing a trade with
the 49ers to go from 12 to 4 which is
something the 49ers considered
you know the falcons were taking a
position player you might have done that
so people believe they're taking a
quarterback
where i have some questions is they
could also be taking
penny sewell who is a franchise future
left tackle
and that value would make a lot of sense
like he could be so good that they say
you know what we're not getting out of
here for anything
you know could they take kyle pitts
possible could they
uh chase probably not but to me it seems
like it's more
sewell pits or a quarterback and i just
i don't know which
but i know that many people who've
had the conversations and do this for a
living believe that they're taking a
quarterback whether they are not that's
what people believe
what are you hearing about the trade
market for for that fourth overall pick
what are you hearing about that um
i i think there there's been some
discussions i mean
the teams that need a quarterback we
kind of know right i mean
i would say the denver broncos would
probably be in the
in the mix of teams that would consider
trading up i think the new england
patriots would be in the mix of the
teams i would consider trading up i just
don't know
you know would the patriots go from
where are they 15
or like that's a you know
i don't know like that's a leap um what
about they go from 15 to eight though
maybe what about dallas from 10 to four
because jerry jones is supposedly quote
unquote infatuated
by kyle pitts what about that one i mean
everybody's infatuated with cockpits
like i think if trevor orange didn't
exist
kyle pitts would probably be the number
one player on almost everybody's board
no kidding
he just you know he's just
it kind of reminds me of it kind of
reminds me of quite nelson in kind of a
weird way
because like yes he's a guard and yes
kyle kids is a tight end right
but everybody loves him regardless of
position so like he's going to go real
high and everyone will be like yeah that
makes sense
but jerry jones is not
in charge i mean he's in charge of
everything but he is not in charge of
the draft room will mcclay and steven
jones are
they have been excellent with
very small exceptions at drafting and
i would say they are the ones who will
make sure that nothing crazy happens
like
trading a future first round pick to go
up for a non-quarterback
are you saying there's a spot in the
cowboys organization where something is
truly delegated and there's no
preemptory
for jerry jones is that what did you
just say the reasons the cowboys have
become
like one of the more stable and stocked
franchises when
that prescott doesn't break his ankle
horrifically
is because of will mcclay and steven
jones stabilizing that thing and
putting an emphasis on value rather than
splash and they have built a really
really really good roster and
organization and locker room
ian rappaport here uh on the rich eisen
show
so is
is there any there there a more you know
i'm wondering between now and the draft
there's always going to be the crazy ass
rumor you know it i know
we know it's coming that russell wilson
could be a quieter after all hey this
you know i understand what's going on
with desean watson and his
legal as we refer to in the media
situation
uh but yeah that that team would
actually be would take desean watson and
can picks would be conditional on the
number of games that he plays based on a
suspension and stuff like that but they
still believe in him and so on and so
forth and
is there any possibility that there
could be still that one blockbuster
trade that
we assumed was going to come uh from the
super bowl till
uh recent days ian
uh possible yeah i would i would say in
this offseason i would not rule anything
out ever
at all i would not rule out a desean
watson trade at some point if the texans
decide to do it which i don't believe
they have yet
or maybe at all if the legal situation
gets clearer
you know at some point before we play
football
possible uh russell wilson trade i would
say less likely
but possible because you know russell
wilson's told teammates he's going to be
there he has not expanded his list of
four teams he would go to
but what if some team makes a hail mary
and says
we're trading for you could you come to
us like would he reconsider
anything's possible um this off season
anything's possible so i would describe
both those as unlikely
but if they happen my head will not i
mean my head will explode but it won't
actually exist
okay so um right now three weeks out i'm
gonna have you back on between now and
then anyway
so you know um call your shot ian
call your shot uh one through five
in the nfl in the nfl draft ian ian
rappaport
mock draft 1.0 right now
right here on the rich eyes and show
call your shot one through five
one through five i don't i don't do a
mock uh
i know you don't i would say but you
have information and you would be able
to give your your excellent best guess
on what you are hearing ian okay uh i'll
give my best guess
and this is just a guess of course it is
you know what it does
and by the way it's sports talk radio
and you could say something it doesn't
matter
and then somebody will say something
outrageous on somebody else's show
and then we we don't pay attention
anymore or one of your other mets will
stick his elbow in the strike zone
and get a win even though you don't
deserve it on the spot
you know we'll be talking about that
don't worry don't worry and if you're
right
guess what three weeks from today we
come on the air and look how right you
were
how great will that be ian it's a
win-win i'll tweet it out too all right
so let's see
so here we go i would say you know
lawrence
and wilson yeah i would say mack jones
three yep justin fields at four
jamar chases five that's my guess right
now
so that would be a dream scenario for
the dolphins to have
the ability to either protect
or just grab kyle pitch and stick him
with gaseki and tell tua
don't even look outside the numbers you
have to worry about it right now just
figure it out yep
you know okay there you go that'll be a
dream scenario
right there all right see that wasn't
that tough
but justin fields in atlanta would be
quite would be quite
something else what would and then this
is the last one for you i've got thomas
dimitrov
coming in hour number two so i'm gonna
really deep
dive deep into atlanta with him and how
this process works with arthur blank
sitting at the top
um what's the clock on ryan with this
contract what does his contract tell us
about what atlanta's maneuverings may be
i mean he's definitely there this year
next year they can figure it out he
could be there two years would be
absolutely fine
um i'm sure they could figure out a way
if they wanted to trade him in two years
they could
we've seen teams trade quarterbacks with
massive salary cap hits and nobody cares
um and by then the salary cap will be
even higher so
at least one year and then after that
we'll see
okay and then in terms of uh how many
more years left let's play that game
with aaron rodgers our jeopardy host uh
how great was that
uh final jeopardy answer for somebody
who wasn't
wagering anything and then just threw
something out there who
why who was the one who kicked the field
goal i have not i have to be honest i
have not watched i'm more of a
priceless right kind of guy i have not
watched very good but aaron rodgers is a
very good football player he is a great
and he's a he's terrific host at this i
don't
did you see the final jeopardy thing
that i'm referring to
did you see that okay so i know and his
answer was very honest and
and aaron's been very very out there um
what about the concept of his contract
and i i think i've asked you this before
and it's been asked have you
what what what to make about his future
in
green bay based on everything that's
happened between the nfc championship
game and now
yeah it's it's very interesting i
honestly don't know i mean i believe the
packers when they say on the record that
he will be there this year that they are
not trading this year
after that i mean what rogers wants is
security
and the team to say contractually that
he is their guy and he will be there for
a long more time and they have not done
it
um they wanted him to convert his
contract for salary cap
he wanted an extension they decided to
do neither
at best the packers left everything
completely open i mean my guess is he'll
play great next year and
yeah of course he'll just keep rolling
but i don't know the off seasons get
weirder
so i wouldn't rule anything out next
year either ian thank you for the call
greatly appreciate it let's do this
again uh
next week i'll ring you up next week if
you're available and then uh and then
we'll we'll see each other in
ohio in short order thanks for the call
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here